we talked a little bit about how images
sickly RGB images are stored in memory
but one interesting question is how do
we obtain those images to begin with
obviously we used to use photographic
film now we've got a huge amount of
consumer cameras on every device that we
have and they almost all use the same
technique to obtain their RGB images all
the cameras that we own will have some
kind of CCD or some kind of CMOS sensor
on which is essentially a photosensitive
layer which will tell the camera how
much large has hit a certain position
and that will be arranged in a grid form
so that each position represents a pixel
in our image and so from the top we
might have something like this we have
some CCD or CMOS elements and then light
from our scene is going to come in like
this now if we just leave it at that
then we're going to get a grayscale
image out because there's no way of
knowing what proportion of this light is
red and what proportion is blue and what
proportion is green because that's not
how these sensors work so what we
instead do is we put a sort of filter
over each of these but filters a
different color so this one will filter
red this one will filter green and this
one will filter blue and then if we do
that over a whole image we can start to
recompute our actual pixel values and we
can work out what color we were actually
supposed to be looking at that filter in
the camera it's a physical thing right
yes
it's a physical set of small elements
that intercept certain wavelengths it's
like a pair of those 3d glasses that you
use where one sides red on one sides
blue but you've also got green ones and
you've got them in a grid arrangement in
front of your your camera's eye if I
have bought a 10 megapixel camera yeah
does that mean only three of the
megapixels are doing green and three of
them are different it does so different
camera manufacturers may have different
ways of doing this but in general what
they do is they split the amount of
megapixels that they've got available on
their sensor into green red and blue as
appropriate and then they interpolate
the values that they're missing the
technique used for this is called the
buyer filter there are other filters but
the BI filters by far the most common so
from the top your your CCD sensor will
look a little bit like this so each of
these represents our photosensitive
element and a part of our filter so we
start off with green and then blue it
each it's a group of four so green blue
and then a green in this corner and a
red in this corner so you can
immediately see already that there's two
greens for every blue and red
and that's because our eyes are more
sensitive to green than they are to blue
and red and we also distinguish
luminance eye brightness with much more
intensity sort of in the green channel
so if you have an image that's captured
using two green elements rather than say
two blue elements it will look sharper
to us and of course this is all about
how it looks to us so this pattern is
repeated but the problem here is that
you've got say 10 megapixels of this
available but you've only captured half
of them as green and the other half is
either blue or red so the amount of red
you've got is not 10 megapixels but they
exploit a nice quality of our eyes which
is that we don't really see color that
well we see it okay but we see grayscale
and luminance much much better so if we
can use a green and to an extent the red
and a blue to create a nice a nice sharp
luminance the fact that the colors a
little bit less high-resolution won't
matter to us and we'll still not nice
and sharp in the image so all we need to
do is to look by the nearby pixels that
have the color we're looking for and
interpolate that value so in this case
we don't have a green value here but we
know what this green value is we know
what this green value is so on a very
simple level we could just pick a green
value which was halfway between the two
and assume that it's nothing complicated
going on and it's a nice green slope and
the same for blue and the same for red
the process of turning a CCD or CMOS
image that's been used with a biofilter
into an RGB image where red green and
blue appear at every pixel it's called D
mosaicing so this is a mosaic we'll say
we've got some samples of green some
samples of blue and some samples of red
and we want all the samples of green and
blue and red and we're going to make
some assumptions about what happens in
the image so we're going to make the
assumption that nothing particularly
complex is going on a moment wienies to
pixels because they're very close
together and so this green is probably
halfway between these ones and this red
here in this pixel is probably halfway
between these two red ones and you've
also got other red ones nearby that you
could use now modern consumer cameras
will do more complicated D mosaicing and
in fact if you shoot in RAW format you
can control the D mosaicing algorithms
in some of these software packages
yourself it will literally be the raw
output of a sensor including any weird
color effects based on the fact that
you've got a bio filter in front of your
sensor so you can do more complicated D
mosaicing algorithms so if we're trying
to capture our blue channel and we've
got a value of 2
100 and a value of 200 and a value of
200 in our neighboring pixels and we
don't know what this one is and we've
got a value of 50 here we could assume
that it's somewhere averaged between
these four values but we could also
assume but perhaps this represents an
edge and this should be 200 because
there's there's a lot of consensus in
this direction that we've got an edge so
more complicated D mosaicing algorithms
will try and preserve edge detail which
is something you will classically lose
in a normal de mosaicing approach it
will go a little bit fuzzy and it may
not matter because you've got let's say
16 or 20 megapixels of your disposal and
this is fitted when you zoom right in
that you're going to see these kind of
problems but for people who are really
interested in image quality they spend a
lot of time looking into this the
downside of the biofilter approach or
any filter that you're putting in front
of your your camera is if you get
decreased chrominance resolutions the
chrominance is what we call them our red
and blue channels luminance is green
generally speaking although obviously
they all represent colors some types of
images like with fast repeating stripy
patterns will look extremely bad after
you try and sort of apply a D mosaicing
algorithm that hasn't been tailored to
that and that's just because we're
making assumptions about the smoothness
between nearby blue pixels and they
don't hold those assumptions don't hold
for certain types of images so that's a
sort of way of taking videos you might
find that certain textures look
particularly bad and it's these kind of
things that are causing that problem
we've got a lot of investment in 8-bit
code how can we exploit that investment
whilst getting into the 16-bit market
and so what we had sketched on the table
was it was effectively a dual processor
system